es una nueva oportunidad para la
legalización del aborto en argentina el
presidente alberto fernández envió al
congreso un proyecto de ley que
legalizaría la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo y garantizaría el acceso
público a este procedimiento
la criminalización del aborto de nada ha
servido
solo ha permitido que los abortos
ocurran clandestinamente en cifras
preocupantes el debate pues no es
decirle sí o no al aborto los abortos
ocurren en forma clandestina y ponen en
riesgo la vida y la salud de las mujeres
que a ellos se someten
por lo tanto el dilema que debemos
superar y si los abortos se practican en
la clandestinidad o en el sistema de
salud de argentina en este país de
mayoría católica el aborto es
considerado un delito salvo en casos de
violación o aquellos en que la salud o
la vida de la mujer está en peligro pero
esto podría cambiar
y yo creo que tenemos posibilidades para
hacer como siempre los votos pueden
estar muy ajustados nunca va a haber una
votación con mucha diferencia de votos
pero tenemos confianza yo creo que
también han pasado cosas se han visto
las muertes que se han producido desde
2018 para acá en 2018 argentina estuvo
cerca de legalizar el aborto hasta las
14 semanas de embarazo pero aunque la
propuesta fue aprobada en la cámara
quedó detenida del senado desde entonces
un fortalecido movimiento feminista ha
hecho de la legalización del aborto uno
de sus principales reclamos una nueva
manifestación para exigir su aprobación
se da cita el miércoles ante el congreso
en el país cada año cerca de 38 mil
mujeres son hospitalizadas por abortos
mal practicados y desde 1983 3.000
mujeres han muerto por esta causa